oder was geht empires erwachsen ich will
einfach mal wieder ein ründchen
minecraft nicht nur ein bisschen kapuze
auf habe ich ungefähr die längsten haare
seit 1000 jahren das mal absolut keinen
sinn
ich vergesse das ja warum ich mal wieder
minecraft spiele einfach bock drauf
hatte regiert gemeinde hätten jetzt
dieses jump blauen das habe ich früher
immer ganz gern gesagt hätten die jetzt
auf ihrem server und das spiel jetzt und
deshalb tue ich das
nebenbei natürlich fragen weil ich finde
dass ist so mit der optimale modus dafür
und ich erzähle auch noch so ein
bisschen was ich so geplant habe ein
letzter zeit kam er sogar kein minecraft
und es gibt natürlich viele die sagen ja
ich habe für minecraft abonniert und
hofft jetzt auch so ein bisschen
eingehen ich fange erst mal mit einer
frage was sind deine größten reiseziele
also ich würde gern mal so selten ist
mäßig reisen irgendwie ach komm ich habe
irgendwie das gefühl dass du ein
bisschen tagen also ich hatte auf jeden
fall bock auf was wildnis mäßiges so
also einfach weil es wahrscheinlich eine
ganz ganz andere reiseerfahrungen ist
als in q1 oder sowas zu zählen
dann hätte auch bock auf die staaten
weil ich dann noch nie war und warum los
maximus also der herr staeck mit mir
fragen stellen lassen
wer mich ein bisschen kennt weiß dass
man nicht bei meinen türen hashtags
nachfragen sollte weil ich nehme einfach
immer irgendetwas dummes was mir gerade
ein chip so würde ich das wirklich smart
machen luca und irgendwann noch mal eine
autogrammstunde wärme gerade erst eine
gemacht in der mayerschen in köln
es waren sehr viele leute da grüße an
alle die daran war echt cool also dem
tag ging es mir zwar nicht so super gut
gesundheitlich aber ich habe
natürlich trotzdem die autogrammstunde
durchgezogen so und so viele leute zu
treffen so hat bock gemacht war okay es
ist auf jeden fall weiter springen
bisschen auf die listen wie war der maut
für dich hier definitiv richtig cool ich
fand es ein bisschen schade dass das er
auf you tube nicht so gut ankam war ich
habe sehr sehr viel arbeit reingesteckt
in die ganzen blogs mehr als ich jetzt
in so einem gaming video oder so ein
stecke und kam zwar relativ gut an aber
es haben sich also es kam sehr gut an
eigentlich also es hat sich halt viele
likes bekommen und so und den leuten hat
es gefallen aber ach schiff misst was
ich schade fand viele haben sich nicht
darauf eingelassen also die haben dann
einfach gedacht wahrscheinlich blogs
keinen bock drauf aber es hat wirklich
den allermeisten leuten gefallen also
die videos hatten zwar weniger klicks
aber trotzdem fast mehr likes also ein
normales gaming video und ich bin okay
wenn das so großen anteil prozentual
gefällt dann würde es wahrscheinlich
noch mehr leuten gefallen die einfach
nur nicht der sache einfach nur keine
chance geben also wenn ihr natürlich
bock drauf habt schickt einfach mal die
playlist aus auf meinem kanal mit luca
also konkret waits und da haben wir ein
paar kugeln blogs gemacht dann komme ich
einfach mal ich mich jetzt einfach alles
ruhig weil ich keine lust drauf habe und
ich sowieso nur verpacke ich möchte
jetzt aber als durch kommen wir zu
plänen mit meinem kanal
ich habe mir so ein paar sachen überlegt
also ich werd ich werde mich an jedem
tag minecraft hochladen so wie ich das
lange zeit gemacht habe weil ich da
irgendwie zeit mich mega das drauf habe
nur mein kopf kanten zu bringen
funktioniert ich habe
geschlossen
ja also ich werde nicht jeden tag mein
schiff bringt und ich werde auch andere
sachen bringen also wenn euch das
gefallen hat so die letzten tage das
aufmaß kam die gta 5 oder so dann ist
das was kuh ist das pro für euch und
ansonsten tut mir leid aber ich hab halt
nicht jeden tag mein fach zu bringen
okay das ist echt einfallslos okay ich
hab voll packt ich gebe ihn zum 15 die
zuflüsse und meine langen haare an dass
ihr euch auf eine kapuze im haus anders
tun kann
ja ja ja soviel dazu also nicht immer
nicht so häufig minecraft wie es davor
kam es kommt auch noch minecraft
community crash möchte ich mal wieder
einführen
ich habe es ja irgendwie ich war dann so
viel unterwegs ich war im urlaub und
dann war ich ab und an mal mittwoch da
und hab auch manchmal vergessen soll und
community klatsch ist ja eigentlich mega
cool so also
das plugin oder was ist mir gelungen
finde ich und deshalb werde ich das
natürlich weiter für den verpassten last
afl bin eigentlich so bei der platte ja
ich hab ich habe jetzt einfach ein paar
sachen überlegt so zum beispiel gedacht
ich glaube einfach mal wieder freunde
ein so die ihr überhaupt nicht kennt die
auf youtube gesehen habt und wir spielen
einfach irgendwie so ein spiel zusammen
sei es jetzt viel 16 oder sowas
auch wenn ich es nicht so super gut kann
darum soll es eigentlich auch gar nicht
gehen um die spiele sondern einfach so
ich jetzt etwa mitglieder freundin des
stadions zu verbinden jetzt soweit man
sieht auf youtube einfach immer nur
youtuber miteinander arbeiten und ich
finde es interessant so dachte ich mir
wenn wir einfach wenn hier was so ein
format machen würde
wo ich mit wenn ich einfach mit meinem
normalen kumpels und so einfach eine
runde zog und wieder weise erzähl was
uns verbindet so wie wir zum beispiel
irgendwann steht in der schule gemacht
haben oder sowas als irgendwelche storys
team zeit verbinden
ich denke mal die ihnen wurde einfach
das plug-in übergeben vom alten server
weil es relativ ähnlich hier und da
denkmal das die das programm haben finde
ich cool und ich mache ja wie gesagt
auch super das macht uns kennen und ich
habe auch auf jeden fall einige weitere
dinge überlegt die relativ
abwechslungsreich sind also ich habe auf
jeden fall ideen ich muss nur schauen
dass ich ja auch mal durchziehen
meine pläne weil ich mag das eigentlich
wirklich gerne ziemlich der denker kein
bock auf youtube sondern ich liebe das
so wenn ich irgendwo etwas mühe gebe das
cool gestalte und das feedback dafür zu
lesen finde ich richtig cool wenn leute
das dann feiern
aber ich bin halt auch ein sehr fördern
sowie dazu also dass wir machen da wo
ich meine game capture hat dafür auch
noch überlegt dass ich so ein
rückwurf damals tag mache wo ich einfach
dann checkt ist falls ihr es denkt weit
öffnen könnt ihr euch überlegen was ich
da mache und auch sonst waren die
jetzige erzählen will
weil ich ja dann auch ganz spannend wenn
es noch ein bisschen überraschung ist
sondern weil damit wir fragen wie sehr
vermisst du lose geschichte ist relativ
ausgeartet ich vermisse blut wer aber
mit luca ist so lustig wir kennen uns ja
aus dem urlaub so wie es früher jedes
jahr einmal gesehen so für zwei wochen
und jetzt mit youtube ist das so lustig
wir sehen es einfach jedes zweite
wochenende oder so früh auf einer skala
von 1 bis 5 sowie sehr lieb so loose
gute frage
tammo aber ich werde kein blut fragen
mehr beantworten weil irgendwie das
gefühl dass das video sonst nur daraus
besteht
hast du schon hast du den blutmond wir
sehen heute nacht das war glaube ich
nicht heute nacht sondern die nacht
davor
ich hab ihn nicht gesehen was daran lag
dass ich krass müde war und da war mir
mein schlaf wichtiger als einen roten
mond zu sehen
ganz einfach darf man nicht haben wenn
man nicht trifft in der regel sage ich
da nein aber manchmal ist es mir
irgendwie so ein bisschen unangenehm
aber ich sage nicht nein
aber nee also kann man eigentlich nicht
so sagen ich finde es halt cool
eigentlich so manche leute zu treffen
und manchmal ist aber so komisch und
dann kommen leute auf mich zugerannt und
umarmen die also ich finds genau jetzt
ich fange vor anderen das problem ist
wenn leute nicht fragen so das finde ich
sehr straight ein video des zum beispiel
hatte ich das schon öfters so das wird
uns sehen wenn ich so an den
absperrungen vorbei
und wieso bekloppte rennens offen zu und
umarmt
mal cool freut so aber ich kann euch
nicht und grenze auch nicht zu als
hätten wir uns drei jahre nicht gesehen
und während die besten freunde
das ist ein bisschen strange also gern
davor fragen dann habt ihr die
möglichkeit nein zu sagen und dann ist
eigentlich auch alles cool deine top
fünf serien platz 1 euro +23 fringe
platz drei fast 4 terra nova platz fünf
ich weiß es nicht genau was könnte ich
das passt in bern führen
irgendeine andere sehe ich habe hier
auch nicht alle auf abruf immer aber die
serie macht sich alles sehr gerne so ein
bisschen in zukunft noch ein erstes
projekt eine serie geplant
hat jemand habe ich eigentlich ein
bisschen beantwort weiß kommt ja eine
ganze menge lustiger abwechslungsreicher
städte nach plan auch regelmäßig soll
fest was kommen nicht nur immer blogs
sondern dass ich einmal pro woche war es
wieder klappt aber soll ich mir noch
eine kamera am zug
und wenn das alles so läuft wie ich
plane dann wäre es cool hoffen dass es
so läuft wie ich dann auf jeden fall
möchte ich mal wieder ein bisschen
konstanter wie diesmal
ich glaube ich auch neuem interesse ok
also dann mach's gut leute das was man
heute einfach mal ein bisschen quatschen
nicht viel geschneit suns und yao bis
dahin macht's gut